hello and welcome to this video playing
rush that's very a bit play much of you
for recently word why not toss in an
English opening so rush is playing the
system let him also playing at the
moment yep 20 this age 5 based system
castles really a small a good move as h5
is dangerous this can still be played of
course now h5 but it's not as
threatening if I'm not cancelled yet I'm
just waiting until now i can cancel it
until he castles ok yeah yeah i think em
why should be a little bit better it
doesn't mind b5 it seems hmmm what to do
i can also play for host here and set to
do that then be five
interesting i did not really take this
into account hmm let's think about this
I can take it also probably not yeah
that doesn't look bad for him home this
Bishop does not look bad and it's
getting a bit more space here with you
for tempo okay yeah that's the tempo on
the rook 96 no I cannot go on he cannot
move the night that's good SB 7s hanging
my idea is this should be three and then
c5
Oh earlier hmm I've got b6 here b6 and
then d5 that in tools to pieces the
bishop on the eight and the night on d 8
whoa now now this game is reduced to the
single question can he somehow bring
those pieces back into the game or not
bubble he allows me to trade all that
that's fantastic let's do that I'm happy
I'm he trades off his only active pieces
and it leaves those two too bad pieces
behind I'm blundering c4 okay yeah that
happens yeah I really do that often if I
opponent placed strategically losing
positions I I just don't pay attention
anymore ah come on that's crazy bloggers
easy for him and now maybe it's still
quite good but the position before
blundering this pawn was just winning
strategically nothing more nothing less
he has to his two pieces down just two
pieces for absolutely nothing okay I
don't mind if you take cnaan h3 because
then I keep keep this bind let's see now
taking doesn't help Queenie for maybe
Queenie for I goes 27
I need to activate you need to activate
this this rook somehow rook to e1 I
guess them i guess i guess i need to go
to you one it doesn't matter that i'm 22
points down really doesn't matter okay
so if i take with the night which would
be ideal a for a singing but can you
take a four-year disposition okay no not
not more time not that's not invest more
time is still playing without the rook
and without the bishop
54 can I take the night take the tags
come on that should win can two pieces
of here Queen you ain't Bishop g7 check
black resigned yeah he's playing two
pieces down it's just what it is I'm
just complete [ __ ] still yeah I mean he
allowed this is this is a crazy move
allowing this position I think this is
digitally winning for white these two
pieces down or three meta how you
counted and then then I totally totally
relaxed there and then blundered c4
which is completely unnecessary of
course so I go ad took it took it twice
and now this is interesting by the way
let's stock fish that the engine is not
evaluating this now okay it is
evaluating somewhat correctly the Evod
those up now one point two is is very
friendly for black yet you know this is
three pieces down basically okay so
Bishop divorce what the engine gives I
absolutely blundered see for the
position I don't know might still be
good but the important thing is if I
play here I'm keeping those parts and if
it takes here I probably just attack
here if I get things underway here and
you see that it climbs quickly 2 + 3 i'm
attacking with extra
Jesus here he's got all those dead root
down yeah i blundered this I just
relaxed like okay I'm winning now and
didn't think much yeah this until I see
five is better that so I expected c5 I
mean here I can I suspect that I should
be better again yeah the ending this
Bishop g5 winning I've played this yeah
I thought about this move but I did not
quite get why it is so strong this ok
thanks ok I key cannot prevent this yeah
I just want I just felt like okay the
rook needs to be on the e-file and this
should also win long run it's just too
much material down the night takes looks
correct but I couldn't quite figure out
how this wins this and this I only saw
96 but ok Quincy 3 is winning this does
you have it now he gets knight c6 but 96
I'm completely sure if you give the
engine more time it will climb up to
something very substantial with every
second this is climbing up I'm told the
show because it will see further and see
that black is falling apart because of
this dead pieces is a very nice example
of of engine depth it just needs more
depth to see how bad it really is we may
said it's just on 0.6 I mean why these
two points down we should not forget
that but still there maybe it needs more
depth even but it shows with two points
down 0.7 is quite a lot and this is
justice
was just just a check to watch him he
has no no way to defend now Queenie 7
check yeah this will set an instructive
game I mean I'm kind of kind of really
annoyed that I let have blundered this
year it just by typical relaxing when I
feel like now I'm winning and then I
play stupid move it's just it's just
extremely terrible what I'm doing that
sometimes but it's nice to see and those
kind of the situation with the pieces
it's quite instructive okay thanks for
watching